[Music]
hi there
can I talk to you for a little bit
did you come inside right now there were
four of them what did we say you
shouldn't make things up when we're
talking about I
can you open the door please
I'm not here to hurt you but you have to
stay here in the cabin with us families
throughout history have been chosen to
make this decision your family must
choose to willingly sacrifice one of the
three of you to prevent the apocalypse
we're not sacrificing anyone for every
no you give us
hundreds of thousands of people are
going to die
foreign
close your eyes
will you make a choice
you have to somehow trust us we're
normal people just like you it doesn't
matter none of us believe you we will
never choose anyone
[Music]
I'm afraid the rule is that no one's
allowed to leave until you choose
do you really think it's all just a
coincidence I have to believe that my
son is gonna die his name is Charlie as
a mother I am begging you apparently
anyone who can stop this Andrew I saw
something there was something in the
light
I failed to choose a world will perish
we've been given the chance to decide
the fate of everyone punch running out
of the world
there is nothing more flawed and perfect
in this world than our family believe
like a choice
I will ask for the last time will you
make a choice
[Music]